[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by the man the myth
the legend ike halls aka brett in the
after party how you doing today ike i
thank you after that intro i'm a lot
better i appreciate you i sent you the
email asking you to call me the myth the
legend and you did it and i appreciate
that
yeah and i hope i follow that email
throughout this whole interview so let
me give it a shot um
was brett's episode though
always going to be the action movie
theme
you know
chris miller is had this idea in his
head for so long and i think when he
kind of originally broke down those
archetypes
i think he you know kind of correctly
identified bret guy
midlife crisis
loves dad movies and uh it just it
really just kind of seems to fit and
then when i read it
being a dad and i'm not in a midlife
crisis yet
um i don't drive a sports car
but i do
i do love action movies um you know i
love like high-end ones like you know uh
die-hards but i also love like random
steven seagal ones like i will almost
always watch one
um so
it just seems to fit you know he feels
like he is that kind of stephen sigali
vin diesel character and in reality he's
just like
just going through a divorce
yeah i know and you do it so well and
what i'm interested about the part of
brett is that you being an actor that's
done drama and comedy and your mindset
are you still approaching it all comedy
in your head or is there like you
looking at if you did like a dramatic
performance
well you know i think i think it's uh
i think it's in moments you know what i
mean i think my kind of natural instinct
is to always kind of
be looking at the cop through the comedy
lens but you know there's definitely
moments in this where
uh you know you kind of have to
feel a little something for brett a
little sympathy you got to kind of
understand why he's kind of doing this
and those moments especially with zoe
especially with
my daughter
uh
you do have to kind of you know
get in that zone but
god bless chris miller very quick to cut
it with like a
good old
diarrhea joke
yeah yeah
it's a good blend and
you know i wonder too this character
rhett now
taking ike let's say ike was in this
party who would you have thought
murdered xavier if you were kind of make
a judgment call oh man that's a tough
one i can't i
without revealing anything how about how
i would say this removing the characters
can i put it through the actors
yes does that make sense okay
so out of the cast of the after party
not the characters
who is most likely
to murder someone
and i'm gonna say
oh god i'm i'm gonna say
i would say maybe jimmy demetrio just
because he's british and i don't know
what they do over there
i don't know what's happening in that
country i don't wanna know
uh
but um yeah maybe possibly him
but as far as the character is concerned
i don't know
no that that's a fair
answer and you made my question even
better so thank you um
is there also what's really on
everyone's mind from seeing this is
there a future scenario where we could
see ike baron hall just you know become
full-on action movie star will you just
listen
i'm glad you're asking this question
this is this has been the talk of my my
uh house for for months now if not years
and finally people are talking about it
more and more uh the answer is yes uh
i've i have conceived a series of
scenarios
for movies action movies that i could be
the star in and
we're right now we're trying to drum up
some interest
uh no but i i honestly i really did you
know i got a little taste of it before
doing like suicide squad and
when you kind of you know you get a you
get a great such a great stunt team and
and working with them over you know a
month or
two months and just getting to kind of
assemble this just awesome fight uh it's
so much fun so yes i am definitely
available i'll even be i'll even be like
the guy who's like
you know they're waiting for you
downstairs what ah and gets like shot
right
i love it so everyone make sure to check
out ike baron holtz in the after party
who kills it as brett it's coming out
this friday apple tv plus and i'm sure
he's going to be the next john wick one
day i thank you so much for joining me
great job in the future